that you don't even know the blood clot
is a light switch
you could just be walking through the
park you're done like that bro like that
and you don't
you don't get the warning sign of the
the it's traveling into your lung or
your brain it's just
you hey bert what calm down done like
light switch
oh that i mean i watched okay my father
died
we found him dead in his bed in the
morning we have to live
then we're on our own my mother we get
put into this home with her this
apartment
she leaves us for weeks at a time to go
live with her boyfriend
and it's me and my two brothers raising
ourselves getting ourselves to school
going every day signing our permission
slips
doing everything then my mother kicks us
out when we turn 18
because she doesn't get the social
security check we move in with my
grandma my dad's mom
a year later a year and a half i'm
sitting
in a little chair just like this there's
a table right here just like this
and a lamp and her stairway goes up here
we're in a little row home
in in baltimore county and my brother's
sitting there with me we just got home
from community college which wasn't a
mile from my grandmom's
and everything's different on a day when
you really go back and look like
the night my father died he was laying
on the couch watching tv
and i always stay up late always and i i
didn't that night i went to bed
and i don't know we none of us know if
he yelled called for out none of us he
just we woke up and he had been dead in
his bed
but my grandmother what usually she
called i'm going to go take five and she
would just lay across her bed and just
chill for five ten minutes a little nap
then up but she always kept the door
open
this day door's shut we're sitting down
there and that door flies open and she
her last words were somebody help me and
then she stood up erect
and i mean boom down on her face arms to
her side
broke her nose nose teeth came out of
her [ __ ] mouth
and my br i'm already on with 9-1-1 and
i was a lifeguard at the time my
brother's at the top of the steps he
doesn't know what to do and
i'm telling a lady i'm a lifeguard i
know cpr so we switch and because they
want you to be on the phone until
the ambulance comes i go to the top of
the steps and
i'm giving my grandmother [ __ ] cpr
mouth to mouth
chest compressions all of it and she had
this picture
right here behind me great great comedy
jam one by the way
oh it was that that's the end of the
world end of the world when they
legalized marijuana oh here's comedy
so there's this picture of jesus on her
wall behind me
and my grandmother's just looking
through me and she's going
and gasping for life and i'm boom boom
mouth you know all the compressions you
know
firemen get there they just throw your
they don't they don't come in and gently
move your [ __ ] they're they'll come in
here right now and flip this [ __ ] out of
the way and they make a big room
they bring her down the stairs they rip
her [ __ ] top open and now you're
seeing that and they're
the paddles have always freaked me out i
had never seen them used on a person but
even in tv just to see a
a lifeless body just a little has always
weirded me out
and they did that and they got a lot of
color back in her she looked
much better i mean she was blue and so
they take her in the ambulance and my
brother goes with her and i stay to give
the police reporting to put the house
back together
and i'm gonna go meet them at the
hospital and um
everyone leaves and i'm by myself i go
to the top of the stairs
and i just see her [ __ ] teeth
in the carpet and i'm picking my
grandmother's [ __ ] teeth out of the
carpet
and i look up on the wall and this
picture of jesus is tilted
and i can't help but think like i think
my grandma was trying to see jesus
when she was tired and i blocked and i
feel like jesus was doing everything he
could
to [ __ ] give her a [ __ ] look and i
think i blocked that [ __ ] vision for
her
and then they called me and told me she
[Applause]
died
oh my god this is our dad and our
grandmom in a handful of years
we now have nobody and i'm looking at
that picture that picture was
like he was like trying to do everything
i think she was trying to get
and then i would go up and and we kept
her home like she had it i never felt
like it was my home and and i would
vacuum and i would hear her teeth
rumble in the vacuum because it was
still in there oh my god
i would [ __ ] i i to this day i will
go straight in a picture if i see a
crooked like it really had an
impact on me because i do think she was
trying to she's like
hey man just a little bit too love your
fat
[ __ ] head you aunt oh my god jesus
is so grand so such a great story
god
[Music]
[Music]
so
you